dress world est une aventure à couper le souffle,
il emprunte une route originale qu'aucun
des autres films n'ose jamais parcourir.
en tant que fan
mais aussi il avait une histoire à raconter à
Stephen, j'ai expliqué pourquoi les gens aiment
ces histoires et quels sont les éléments
qui se sont connectés avec des personnes de plus de 22
ans que nous voulions essayer de
reprendre pour une nouvelle génération, nous avons tous
convenu que c'était  ça va parler de l'
histoire et des personnages parce
que c'est ce qui vous fait croire aux
dinosaures comme si les gens se sentaient réels
quand je vois Colin sur le plateau il sait ce
qu'il cherche il recherche ce
sentiment en lui qu'il a
ressenti quand il a regardé  le premier
Jurassic Park il est fan de Jurassic
Park je me sens à l'aise de savoir que
c'est entre les mains de Colin car il est
aussi fan il y a une responsabilité
assurez-vous que vous
livrez quelque chose qui colle avec
le thème dont les gens qui ont fait cette
franchise seraient fiers donc et si je
pouvais aspirer à quelque chose dans mes films, je
veux qu'ils aient une âme et je pense que ce
film fait de l'action
vous